which Google Cloud certification is
right for me okay so you're ready to
take your career to the next level with
Google Cloud certification but not sure
which one is right for you let me help
you figure that out if you are a
business professional looking to learn
about the capabilities of cloud the
cloud digital leader certification is a
perfect fit for you if you're more
Technical and enjoy Hands-On work
consider associate Cloud engineer
certification you'll learn how to
configure deploy and Implement Cloud
Solutions but if you love working with
customers and it teams to build complex
Cloud Solutions the professional Cloud
certifications like Cloud architect or
data engineer or any of these other ones
maybe you're calling so what are you
waiting for find your passion and choose
the cloud certification that's right for
you start with Google Cloud skills boost
where you will find all kinds of
Hands-On labs for your interest good
luck on your Cloud Journey